サッバパーパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダー サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナサーサナン
はい よろしくお願いします
あの 今日の法話会のお布施は
あの黒田武弘様でございます
あの ほとんど毎日のようにいろいろいろんな形でお布施している人で
まあ私に移動させる時の足にもなっていて
いろんなところに自分の車で運転してくれるし
今日も同じく黒田さんの車でここまで来ましたし
で とてもあの おばあちゃん御法話で
あの自分のおばあ様がね
4月に亡くなられて 名前は黒田玲子様ですね
だから 自分が大変お世話になったそのおばあちゃんの供養のために
解脱のために 輪廻転生するときでも
一度たりともね 不幸なところに行かないようにという優しい心で
慈悲の気持ちで今日の開業の日をね
定めて法性をなさいました
ですから あの これは功徳の中で一番高い功徳でありましてね
お布施の中でも まあ功徳というよりも
お布施の中で一番高いお布施でありまして
迷っている世の中 誰一人も幸福になる道っていうのは誰一人も知らない
この世の中 だから仏教は
生命は暗黒に来ているんだよと
暗黒にいるし 目も見えないし
しかし光を求めているんですね
幸福という だからそれ唯一光の案内するのは釈迦牟尼仏お釈迦様なんですね
ですから 人類を助けるならば
生命を助けてあげたければ
法政することであると説かれてありますね
ですから これは仏法僧にたりするお布施でもありながら
人類に智慧の灯が現れますようにという
すべての生命に対するお布施でもありますね
だからかなり徳が高い行為になります
善行になります で ところで
この黒田玲子様が幸福でありますように
輪廻転生する中で 常に幸福なところでいられますように
心が清らになりますように
解脱に達するために この功徳が糧になりますようにと
祝福誓願いたします 皆様もあともう3回
サード サード サード それから黒田さんの家族のお母様とかね
兄弟がいらっしゃいますので
家族の方々とまた親戚の方々と
自分が幸福になりたいと思っている他のね
親戚関係の方々とも この功徳が入りますようにと
この功徳の力で 黒田家の皆様方は幸福でありますように
幸せでありますように
涅槃に解脱に達することができましょうにと誓願いたします
サード サード それから
今日の法話会に参加する皆様方にも
三宝の報がありますように
悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
心に智慧の光が現れますように
心が心の煩悩がなくなりますように
解脱に達することができましょうにと誓願いたします
サード サード サード では
そういうことで話に入ります
で 今日はそんなにたくさんしゃべることはないんですね
あの えっと えーと 無償有 cost というね
IT  AI が導く現代社会とブッダの道
順番で人類の運命をね
考えてみましょうね で
最初はこの単純な生き方がどんどんすごい複雑な生き方に変わっている
人間の社会ですね 初期時代で生きるために労働が必要でしたが
金や物は必要ではなかったんですね
いわゆるみんな言ってる
このハンターギャザラーというこの食事時代の人間というのは
まあ何か獲物を取って
何か木の実を取って 芋を取って生活する
お金かかりませんね だからすごいシンプルなんです
ただ体力が必要なんですね
すごいシンプルな生き方をしていたんですね
生き方がシンプルだったら
困ることもすごく狭くなるんですね
例えば狩りに行ったら自分が獲物にならないようにとかね
そんな程度で また森を歩いていて
早くも食べられるものが見つかりますようにとかね
そんな程度ですね そこで所有するという問題が出てきますね
だから自然はすべて生きるために必要なものは提供しています
自然は何も人種差別も生命差別もないんだからね
どこかというと 自然界で生命を支えるものがあるんです
各生命が自分でそれを取らなくちゃいけないんですね
所有しなくちゃいけないんですね
自然界は口の中に食べるものは入れてはくれません
で 支えるために必要なものはいくらでもあります
じゃあ自分の力でそれは所有しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから 当時の人間が所有した品物っていうのは
そのその人の力によりものなんですね
だから この所有するものにそんなに執着する必要あるのかというと
まあないと思いますけど
昔の人は知らんから 我々はね
推測で喋ってるだけだから
だから もし昔の原始時代の人々にも所有欲があったならば
結構余計な苦しみが入ると思います
例えば自分が拾ってきた芋が自分の住んでいるところに家はないんだからね
ちょっとしたシンプルなハッですね
あるいは洞窟ですね そこでイノシシか誰か来て
もう全部食べて行っちゃったらね
それはあり得ることでね
なんだこりゃとね せっかく焼いて食べようと思っていたものはね
こいつらに乗っ取られたと食べられたというふうに怒ったりすること
あり得る あるいは逆にまあいいや
また取ってきますということもできるし
あるいは逆に他の動物にまた取られる前に
自分たちでこれは食べましょう
焼いて食べましょうということもできる
だから人はどう判断したのかわからないんだけど
初期時代 初期時代ではそんなに所有する必要があったんだけど
所有欲はまあ実際はいらないんですね
その失敗したかないかよくわからない
なぜならば 所有だけする所有欲もある
人二人を比較すると 所有だけしている人の芋がイノシシに食べられた
その人はあ 芋が食べられちゃった
じゃあどうしよう まあまた探しに行こう
今は遅いだから暗いんだからね
しょうがない  お腹が空いたままで寝ようと
危険だからってことはできる
所有欲ある人が はっ イノシシめに盗まれた
もう取られた 食べられた
こいつを教えなくちゃいかんとかね
罠を仕掛けなくちゃあかんとかね
でもものすごく怒りで
憎しみで 苦労して夜も寝られない状態になる
精神的に苦しくなっちゃうんですね
あるいはあまりにも欲があって
もう午後なのにまた行って取ってやるぞと行って
森に入っちゃって危険な目に遭う可能性もあります
だから そのシンプルケース
2つ比較してみると見ましょう
だからイノシシの芋が取られただけのケースなんですね
一人がまあまあ損しちゃった
まあいいやということで落ち着いている
なぜならば 所有はしたが
所有はしたんだから その分なくなったという
ちょっと不都合な結果もある
そこで問題は終わり  2番目の人には所有したが
所有欲もあったんだから
ちょっと不都合だけで終わらなくて
精神的に激しく苦しむことにもなるんですね
だから 二人とも結果は同じだから
なんで余計に苦しむのかと
二人にも夜食べるものなくなっただけなんですね
だからしょっちゅうお腹が空いたままで昔いたんだから
まあ一晩ぐらいは大したことはないし
しかし 所有欲あった人には損が多いんですね
なぜならば この感情で作った怒り
嫉妬 憎しみっていうのは
いくらでも拡張することができますね
次の日も 次の日も それ考えることはできますしね
困ることはできます 苦労することはできます
そこで 例えばこの二人がね
まあ所有欲がない人がね
なあ 今日はいろいろ木の実やら芋やら取っちゃってね
イノシシに食べられないようにしてやるぞと面白くて
じゃあできることなら取ってみろとか
なんか上どこかにぶら下がって置いたりとか
なんとかするかも それでその人の技術能力は開発するし
かえって面白くなってくるんですね
同じ真似を 2番目の人としても
所有欲があるんだから
そこでイノシシに対してすごい怒り
憎しみがあるんですね
この人もなんか葉っぱでこれ結んで上にぶら下がるようにしたかもしれませんだけど
怒りは消えませんね そういうことで
この石器時代で人間がいたのではないかと推測はします
それから物を所有することが優先する時代です
それで人間が進化するんですね
物は所有するべきといって
所有する 所有する 所有するってことになる
そこで現代までサーッとその流れですよ
現代人もたくさん物を所有するべきやと
ありったけのものを自分のものにしなくちゃいけないと思っているのです
その場合は確実に所有欲があるのです
所有する必要だけだったら
自分と自分の家族に必要なものでストップするのです
だからあのハンティング
あるいは石器時代の人々と比較するとね
所有欲のフルバージョンですね
現代人が所有だけじゃないんですね
だから 石器時代の人々よりは
今の人々の悩み 苦しみと涙っていうのはものじゃないんですね
はい そこでまあまあ そこをなんとか書いたんだけどね
我々には所有してこれで結構というそれもないんですね
金ならいくらあってもいいし
車ならね 何台あってもいいし
家なら何軒あってもいいしね
そういう風にまあ夢だけ見てるんですね
誰も車台くらい持ってるバカがいませんしね
でもあれば悪くないとは思っているんですね
アメリカでもスイスでもね
あのスカンディナビアの国のどこかででもね
家があって悪くないと
楽ちんやと あちらこちら旅行できて住めるんだ
欲だけは実際はできないんだけどね
だからもう欲だけ限りなく広がっちゃうんで
だからあれ欲しい これ欲しいと思うことで精神が壊れていくんです
それってすごいネガティブ
ネガティブフォースです
ネガティブ力なんです
みんな気づいてね これポジティブ thinking と思ってるんで
とんでもないことです
例えば私は外車が欲しいなとかね
高級車欲しいね ありがたいね
あればとかね それはどんな意味ですか？無意識にメッセージ送ってるんですよ
これをサジェスチョンと言うんですけど
自分の無意識にこのサジェスチョンやってるんですね
お前には金がない 能力がない
どうしようもないと だから自然に自分の心に無意識で俺はダメな人間だよとはっきりと情報を送っているんです
その反応で欲しい欲しい欲しいということは表面的に見えてくるんです
だから何にでも裏と裏と表があるんだから
表面的にはポジティブポジティブだと思って威張ってる人々は
内面的に真っ暗ネガティブなんです
だから実際 命がこの内面のフォースで力で生きているんです
表面の力ではないんです
表面の力は日常の仕事で終了するんです
人生そのものを管理するのは
この内面的なパワーのフォースなんですね
それがあまりにもネガティブだったら
もう想像できないことになる
で 面白いことはみんな麻痺しているんだから感じないね
苦しんでいるんだと だから現代人はこの罠にはまっているんでしょうね
だから自分が出所で これだけで十分だというふうに生きていたくなっても
自分の友達が 仲間が 周りがまた違うものをいろいろ持っているしね
だから所有するものの差が結構あるんですね
たとえ友達も自分も同じところで家を作っても
もしかすると自分が買った土地よりは友達の家の土地の雰囲気がいいかも
どうしましょうかね 環境は周りがいいかも
窓から遠く山が見えるかも
自分の家の窓から山は見えないとかね
だから 例えば同じものを所有しても
そちらに差が現れるんですよ
だからかなり危険なんですね
ああ いいな 自分にもあった方がいいなと思う
家がもうどうにもならんでしょう
もう買っちゃって作ったんだから
あの あの なんかあの人々は
あの いろんなところで歩き回っている人々いるでしょ？定住する場所がなくてね
そんな感じだったらね
まあまあ 浮き輪じゃあこちらで住んで
それからあちらに行きますとかね
戦鼓叩いて ゲルトとかあれこれ叩いて
馬の上に乗ってって そういうこともできないしね
だから一番危険なのは現代時代なんですね
現代人間はもう悟りづらくてね
死んで嫌になっているのも
頭がもう使い物にならないんですよ
頭と心はクタクタ壊れてるんですね
まだ壊れつつですね 悪いことはもう心は壊れちゃって
それで機能停止だったらいいんだけど
心っていうのは この放射線と同じく連鎖反応でずっと続くんだから
それはとても苦しいことになりますね
だからこの所有する習慣が原始人にもあったんです
それでずっと所有することこそが生きることだと勘違いしちゃって
これ欲から出てくるんです
だから現代人にまでその流れが進んできて
とにかくすべて所有してやるぞと
今 ほぼほぼ頂点に立たそうとしているんです
この所有の危険性 今 人類のすべての人間の財産は
だいたい 20人程度の人々が握っているんですね
見事に成功してますでしょ
所有することに だから我々一般の人々は
本当に地球の財産のほんのわずかな分しか使っていないで所有できないんですね
皆様にはね あのザッカーバーグとかね
昔の前のビル・ゲイツとかね
そんな風に金持ちにならんでしょうね
あるいは石油を持ってる会社とかね Google
とかね アマゾンの社長とかね
どうしますかね これ 我々現代人知ってる人々はですよ
もっと裏にもっとひどい連中いるんです
すべて収入がそちらに行くんです
それはさらに今拡大していくんです
現代時代っていうのは
このすべての財産 できるだけ何人かのところに揃う方向にシステムまで作っているんです IT
というのはそういうシステムなんです
みんな何どんな嘘を言ったっても
私には関係ないんです
それは人々の財産が 1箇所に
止めてもらう仕組みなんです
だから我々を檻に入れた動物のように管理しているんですね
我々はもう今も動物園のいる動物の立場なんです
餌をくれたら食べて 俺は元気で歩く
歩くぞと言ったって 檻の中
じゃあ走ってやるぞと思っても
檻の中 何のこともないよ
携帯でね いろいろメッセージを送ったり
情報を取ったり ああ 世界につながっているんだよと
どうで そんなことつながってないんです
ただ管理されているだけで
与える状況を見ているだけ
だからどうにもならんでしょうね
私たちにもいろんなことを発言できる
たまに誰かが見るかも
だから何かなる いくつかのサイトのコメントを見たら
ある人がこう書いてるんで
どうかお願いしますから
私のサイトはフェイスブックかもしれませんだけど
このあの登録してください
サブスクライブしてくださいと
それでサブスクライブ登録者の数が増えると
いくらか収入が入るみたい
コマーシャルでね それは自分がこのカメラセット買いたくなってるんだと
そうすると私はそれ買いますよと
なんか悲しく感じるんですね
私は だからシステムの中にもう閉じ込められているんですね
だから動物園の猿がお客さんが来ると手を出して何か餌ちょうだいと言っているような状態
動物園で餌あるんだけどね
ちょっと手を出してピーナツ一つ一個二個ぐらいもらってやろうと
悲しいんですよ それって人間かと
それで私たちは猿のこと
動物園のケージに猿のことなんか見下すんだけど
でも猿は知らないね それが
お客さんが来るとウロウロといって手を出せばいいと思う
それ成功よ 私は成功や
他の猿たちよりはと ピーナツ全部私一人で取ってやったよと言われたけどもね
だから猿は自分が惨めな姿でいることに気づいてないような感じで
我々現代人も自分があまりにも惨めに生きていることに気づいてないんです
それははっきり私が敵視するだけで
それで私も全然悲しくならないんです
それって面白いんです
はい ですから このフロムシンプリシティーマルチシティーと書いたんだけど
単純なところから複雑なところに進んだと
だから全ての人類の歴史はこの 1 ページで完結です
人間の歴史とは まあ所有することを拡大するだけ
それで必要かどうか どうでもいいんですね
例えば わざわざと所有欲があるんだから芸術作品があるんだよと
それでわざわざと値札を上げるんですね
上げて上げて これ 1 枚の絵画がもう 5億円だよと言って
誰かが買っちゃうんですね
所有するんですね 所有して展示するかと
しないです 一生懸命大事に保管するんです
何よ これと なぜ人類の一番大事なありがたいものは公で使えるようにしないんですかね
みんなに見られるんだと
一部はみんなに見られるようになりますけどね
でも所有したいんですね
そこで科学は発展しているでしょう
科学で知識は増えて 知らないものは知るということが起こるんだけど
結局実際やっているのは所有欲を拡大することです
だから かつてあるとも知らなかった金具を今作って売っているんですね
だから私たちはそれを買わなくちゃと馬鹿を見るんです
IPHONE の車で聞いたんだけど
新しいバージョン出来てるんだよとね
結構高いという話は私も聞いたんだけど
新しいものあるんだから買わなくちゃと
あれは我々頼んで作ったんですかね
こういう機能は必要だと
ないんです どこかが勝手に妄想して勝手なガラクタを作るんですね
そこで我々は猿と同じく
ああ 買います 買いますということになるんです
だから 不必要なものを所有するためにはどうしても感情が必要です
所有欲が必要です 貪瞋痴が必要です
例えば 移動することは必要な人はね
東京と違ってね 地方になるともうどうしてももう歩いて行けるところじゃないんですね
で 車が必要ですね それでそこら辺に売ってる
売ってる簡単な車で物は積みますけど
そういう人は外車が欲しいと思っちゃうと
それは何なのかと 煩悩でしょ
明らかに そういうことで心の変化が見えてくるんですね
必要から欲しいへと心が退化するんです
これは進化ではないんですよ
心がすごいひどい罠にはまってしまうんですね From
needs to wants という風になってしまうんですね
最初は必要なものを探し求めた
だから石器時代で必要なものを探したんですよ
雨が降ってもうもうちょっと大変だから
なんか住むところを探そうと
必要でしたからね 寒くて震える
ちょっと何か体なんとかした方がいいとね
これ あのシベリアとかそこら発掘するとね
あの あの マムシ動物いるでしょ？ゾウさんと同じくね
あれの皮を取って もうなんか作って
もう中に隠れて寒さに耐えられるんですね
だからそれって今更見るとすごい残酷なんですけど
当時の人たちにはこれ必要でしたね
必要なものには制限があります
面白いことは 必要なものには必ず制限があります
だからマンモスがいた時代で
ものすごい  それは雪 寒いところで生活していたんだからね
あの動物はね だから動物を一つ倒すこともそう楽じゃないし
かなり大きいんだから
今のゾウよりはものすごい体が大きい
耳が小さいだけで それで皮を剥がして
自分の動物の中に周りに入れて下に敷いてもらう
だから一つそのハットを作れば十分でしょ
ただ 家族が４人ぐらいいる １
個で十分です あと３つも作りましょうとはないんですね
だから この必要なものにはどうしても制限がある
お腹が空いたならば 何か食べなくちゃいけない
いくらでも食べられるということはありえないね
だから食べることは必要です
必要なものにはリミットがあります
ということは そういう気になれば
我々は幸せだと満足することはできるのです
すべて揃っているんだと
何も必要はないんだと
それで人間にとってはリミットがあるんだから
食べるもの 住むところを作ったら
これでもずっと雪で壊れるまで
使えるんだから だからハットを作るまでは時間かかったんだけど
十分 あのマンモスの皮をね
取る場合はもう一年もかかったかも
でもそれでも終わりでしょ？時間余るでしょ
もし獲物を一匹大きい獲物を取ったら
それはもう結構二 三週間食べれます
一ヶ月間でも食べれます
雪だから腐らないしね
まあ腐ったでも当時そんなことわかってないしね
だから時間の余裕が出てくるんです
どうしようかと 余った時間で
そこで必要なものではなくて
欲しい だから自分が作ったハットに
あの木の棒でそこを刺せるんじゃなくて
マンモスの象牙だったらいいんじゃない？これで一本二本じゃなくて
全部壁はそこで立てて
そこいいんじゃない？と欲で増えてくるんですよね
欲しいというとは感情なので
妄想すればいくらでも拡大します
問題は 欲しいという欲が出てくると
いくらでも妄想でそれは拡大できます
例えば 自分がもっと広い場所に住みたいと
周りは他の人がいると獲物にも問題があるし
もううるさいし 私はもう結構自分の縄張りを広げて胸を張って生きていきたいという欲しいも出てくるでしょ
それはいくらでも拡大できます
グループのボスになってやるぞとかね
何のためかよくわからん
そういうグループのボスになりたいと思う人がいるんです
それって昔ですね そういう風に
欲しいとは妄想の結果ですから
いくらでも拡大できます
したがって 欲しいものには制限がない
欲しいものを得て満足しますということはありえないんです
幸せは決して感じないんです
さらに不幸を感じるんです
必要なものを犠牲にしてでも欲しいものを求めることも現代はあるんです
現代人は必要なものをされ
それは犠牲にする それで欲しいものを得る
現代人は欲しいものの海に溺れているんです
現代人はなんで生きることは大変で
金がいくらあっても足らないし
もうもう本当に毎日問題ばっかりですね
例えば普通の家を守っている主婦の方々はもうあまりにもクタクタ精神的に疲れているんですね
肉体的に疲れちゃったと言ったら
これ誰だってよくわかりますね
朝から晩まで子供の面倒を見るのは結構大変です
ああ 疲れちゃったと 言ったら周り誰かがもうベタんタッチしてあげますよ
別に しかし なんで主婦の方々は主婦業の方々はクタクタ精神的にやられているんですかね
だから指圧に行くわ マッサージに行くわ
もう切りがないんですね
どこに行っても問題はそのままです
だから現代人が頭が変になっちゃって
欲しいものを狙っているんですね
だからリミットがない
だから満たせない 精神的に
だから あの 何と言いますか
インターナル あの 自分の内心はね
心の裏は内側 ずっとネガティブでないないない
欲しい欲しい やーだー
なんで旦那の給料上がらないのかとかね
上がったってもこんなもんですかと
5万円上がってどうにもならんよ
だってこの人は500万のことを欲しがっているんだから
さっさと計算するんです
生活基準はそのままに置いておいて
あの余った 5万円を貯金してやると
それで 500 になるためには 10ヶ月とかかかりますね
だから 1年も待って待って
悩んで悩んで やっと欲しいもの手に入ると
まあその時年取ってるんだからもういらなくなっているんですね
結局は だからそういう本当に心配で苦しんでますよ
みんな だから我々の周りを見ると
必要不可欠というものはほぼないね
全部必要ではなくて 欲しいものでいっぱいです
溺れていますよ 陸が見つからず溺れて人生を終えます
だから現代人は誰でもあんなもうリミットのない不満で一度たりとも幸せを感じることがなくて
いらない欲しいものの海に溺れて死んでいるんです
だから海に溺れる人が何とかして海から逃げなくちゃあかんでしょうに
島を見つからなくちゃあかんでしょうに
お釈迦様が人間の生き方を海にたとえて
仏道が島を教えていますよと言ってますよ
島を見つけ見つけなさいと
島も自分自身だよと アッタディーパーディシェと最後に説かれた言葉なんです
お釈迦様が すごいかっこいい言葉なんです
だって溺れてるのは自分の心でしょ？欲しい欲しいと思っているのは
だから心が欲しい これいる？と自分で聞いてね
これなかったら私が死ぬ
これがなかったら私には笑えない
なんでバカなことするのかと自分自身を観察すると島は見つかるんです
海から抜けるんです 島に上がった人はまた海に飛び込まない
で 海が欲しい世界 島の場合は
まあいくらか必要なものはあるかも
必要なものは揃いますよ
問題ないです だからこれ
仏教的には 現代人がこの苦しみの海に溺れて
解決し 糸口って全く見つからず苦しんでいるんです
だから現代社会発展はすごいそういうことをやらせているんです
社会発展っていうのは
いらんものだけに溢れている社会なんです
いらんものだけど 欲しいんですね
はい そこでダブルエッジフリータイムというタイトルを付けたんだけど
おそらく諸刃の自由でしょうね
日本語でしては うん まあ後でやめたんで
英語で考えて日本語にすると面倒くさいんだから
病気で体も壊れていたしね
だからまあ 朝 2時半から 5時まで作り込んだんです
生活は成り立つとフリータイムが現れるんですね
それ説明しましたね 食べるものも手に入った
住むところもある だからその 1日やることはないんです
フリータイムです そこで必要が満たしているので
欲しいものを考えるんです
もしかすると最初の初期時代でね
まあ全部満たったんだから
じゃあ歌ってでもみようかなと
だから別に音楽 ミュージックはなかったんだけど
なんとなく喜びの気持ち
音に立てる 音にして あるいは動物たちの鳴き声を真似たりする
それで楽しくなってくる
それにはフリータイムが必要なんですね
そこは今の音楽文化まで発展しちゃったんです
だからフリータイムで欲しいものを考えたんですね
そこでですよ 文化 文明
知識などもさらに楽に生きられる方法も作り出したが
そのフリータイムで使ったのは
文化は文明を作るために
文明っていうのは 古代文明でもちゃんと水路があって
下水道があって みんな沐浴する
用水する場所があって
いろいろすごい発展していたんで
昔も古代文明でも それで知識ね
古代人にも知識あったでしょうに
だからいまだに読めないでしょ？モヘンジョダロハラッパの文字は
そこでクニフォームというなんとか楔形文字もあるでしょうね
それからヒエログリフというエジプトでもね
まあ文字があったでしょうにね
それでテキスト書いたりもしますよ
今の人々だけ文化と知識で優れているとか
どういったことはないんですよ
今の人間がピラミッド作れませんだからね
そこで作り出したが 感情
争い 憎しみ 奪い合いも
信仰 宗教 迷信も現れるのです
フリータイムで 最初のきっかけは欲しいということなんです
それで現代時代が現れたんです
学問 科学とともに様々なものが現れて
最後に IT も AI も現れてくる
まだ完成していないんです
IT も AI も 今は作っているんです
ただ 不思議というあの感情の拡大だけです
だからこれ諸刃の諸刃でしょうに
だから文化が悪いくはないでしょ
知識悪くないでしょうに
科学悪くないでしょうに
だからこのダブルエッジというのは
あの辞書 辞書の意味は結果 2つあります
ワンイズネガティブ ワンイズポジティブと
で 辞書で定義しています
ダブルエッジという あの諸刃という言葉の意味
どちらでも切れる だからフリータイムというのは
そのような諸刃の何だらかんだらですね
ダブルエッジソードですね
だから科学 医学 悪くないよ
それでエンジニアリング悪くないんで
だからこのホールもこのテクノロジーでできたものでしょうに
しかし料金高いね この
だって使う場合は制限
制限 制限 制限 あれやっちゃいけない
これはやっちゃいけない
お金払ってるくせにね
ガチャガチャ言うんです
だからみじめで使わなくちゃかんです
それでみんないや そんな態度取るんだったらって言って
このホール借りなかったら
このホールの持ち主の人々はどうしますかね
収入がないんだから維持管理費がなくなっちゃって
だからそういう世界でしょうに
だからこれ諸刃 諸刃でしょう
フリータイムは それで IT というね
インフォメーションテクノロジーっていうのはね
まあ世界の情報はすぐ取れるし
自分にもすぐ情報発信できるし
で 我々協会もね まあ会議
大会 会議をやるんだけど
ネットでやってるんですね
だからみんな自分の家でいて参加するんです
だからそれ  IT があるからでしょ
でなきゃ京都から来なくちゃあかんだからね
東京に だから助かる部分もありますよ
同時に社会は危険に陥れることもあります
そこでサイバー サイバーテロが入ったらどうなる？誰かが日本の政府のシステムに
銀行システムに割り込んで全部破壊したらどうなる？ちょっとウイルス埋め込んだら
あるいは原子爆弾やら精密大量破壊兵器もコンピューターで管理する
システムで管理するでしょ
そちらにちょっと誤った情報でも
だってつながってるんだから
どうしようもない ファイアウォールあると言ったってもね
大したこと全部つながってるんです
ハッカーにはこのファイアウォールは大したことない
ハッカーは知ってます
ファイアウォールを作るならば
こういうこういうアルゴリズムで作るだよと知ってますから
それ破ります なぜならば
IT のこういうシステムというのは
アルゴリズムという言語があって
順番というのは決まってます
それはもう変えられませんね
だから知ってる人には別に
もう手のひらのあるもののようにわかっちゃうんですね
だからあまりにも危険ですよ
現代は 例えばアメリカ軍人の人でもね
そういうアクセスできる人がね
ちょっと不機嫌になったところでボタンを押したらどうする？あるいは時間かけて指令埋め込んで
自分が退職して帰ったらどうなる？時間になってくるとドカーンと爆破するとか
そういう素晴らしい社会になってます
今は 安全で仕方がないね
だから何でも諸刃です
覚えてください 調子に乗ってはあかん
理性ある人は利益だけ取って
悪いところはね もうカットするべきなんですけど
人間にこれできないんですよ
人間ってそもそもバカなんです
例えばチュビチュビって酒飲んでもいい
でも体の疲れがなくなって
ちょっと脳がちょっとおかしくなりますけど
なんか脳がちょっと機嫌になっちゃって楽しくなる
その程度にストップすればいいのに
やっぱりもう一杯飲むでしょ
それからあれがネガティブに変わっちゃうんです
今麻薬だと開発している品物はもともと薬なんです
時々いろいろ病気にかかっちゃうと
これは薬で治せないんですね
体が治さなくちゃいけない
だから体にホルモン出すのは脳なんですね
だから脳をちょっと騙してホルモン出させてもらう
で ホルモン 正しいホルモンを出すと
あの病気が治っていく
だからそういう病気もあります
例えば 知らないうちに腎臓が低下しようとしている
肝臓が低下しようとしている
復活させなくちゃいけないんですね
普通の薬ではどうにもならない
手上げです そこで脳に行って
これ修復するホルモン出せと
だから脳は言うこと聞かんだからね
それで薬あげるんです
それすごい気をつけて量を知って
で これは４回しか使ってはいけないから
こういう昔のお医者さんが４つしかあげない
作り方も教えてあげない
自然の品物を作るんだけど
それでそちらで現代麻薬という成分が入ってます
でも自然なものだから
体に悪影響もなく 医者がくれたものだから
薬終わったら黙ってるしかないし
振り返ってみると自分の体がよくなっているんです
それがバレちゃって 今麻薬のために使っているんですね
だからアーユルヴェーダ世界ではそういう治療システムが完全停止しちゃったんです
まあどうしようもなくなったんです
だから人間というのはもうすごい立派で馬鹿なんです
要するに この物事はものの葉っていうことは
教えたっても やっぱり
ネガティブの方を取ってしまうんですね
だから我々は何を使用しても
ポジティブ ネガティブ両方あるんだよと知って
ポジティブの方を受け取って
ネガティブの方を極力避けるというね
ことをしなくてはいけないんですね
それでどうして我々は草の種を食べているんだからね
あの 種だから大体栄養は全部揃っているんです
で ある程度で美味しいしね
食欲あるんだから美味しくも感じる
もっと美味しく感じたいと
あれって余計でしょ？欲しいことでしょ
それで我々は全部脱穀して真っ白い純粋
あの なんていうんだ カーボハイドレートだけね
食べてるでしょうに これで栄養は入るんだけど
かなり危険でしょうに
大量にカーボンが入るんだから砂糖が
それで体が壊れていくんだけど
もう遅いんですね それで止まらないよ
チャーハン食べてるんだからね
誰も玄米でチャーハン作ろうと考えたことないでしょ？私以外は
だから人間バカなんですよ
ご飯にしても トウモロコシにしても
何にしても 例えばリンゴにしたっても
ダベレッシュなんです
そこを区別して気をつけること
能力は人間になんです
科学者も同じ物の見事なアホなんです
だから作っちゃえばいいと思っているんです
それからどうなるのかはわからない
例えばインターナルコンバッションマシンという
あの 燃やしてエネルギーを作る機械ね
あ これが便利やと思って作るは作るは飛行機まで
だから化石燃料を使うは使うは
これって考えれば化石だから量がありますよと考えてないんです
あんなことを忘れるんです
そこで自然はどれぐらいこの破壊に耐えられないのかと
こんなことは考えてもなかったんです
言っても無視する 麻薬中毒と同じなんです
言っても言っても 麻薬中毒の方は取るんです
原発もそうでしょう 原子を爆破する技術を求めたんです
それでびっくりして止まればいいでしょうに
あの 何でしたっけ？いい子
MC スクエアでしょ あのアインシュタインの相対のフォーミュラが
それでウラニウム爆発させて見せたんです １
グラムのウラニウムがどれぐらい力を持ってるのかと
想像できんやと量はと
それじゃ原発作ろうと原爆作ろうと
バカでしょ それで今 原発
原子力発電所を作ったでしょうに
あの爆破やない それから放射線どうするのかと
いまだに考えたことがないんです
ちょっと考えれば 放射線をストップさせる
ロックさせる 何か技術開発できますと思う
私はただもう考えるだけの人間だからね
そう考えちゃうんです
ま やってないんですね
ですから 皆様方はね 世界一天才やと
ノーベル賞持ってるんだからといって乗ってはあかんよ
バカです みんな 人間にその能力は本来ないんです
後で書いてあります 生活に悩んでた人は
現代では生活にはなくても問題がない
アクセサリーのために殺しています
現代人はアクセサリーを求めをしている
生きるためにはほとんど必要ないんです
だからもう一部言ったんですね
無知 IGNORANCE
IS THE GOD だから無知は神ですと日本訳してもあんまり迫力ないんですね
これ 英語のフレーズでは私は言いたいことははっきり ignorance で
先人先祖の神様とは無知のことやと
必要と欲しいの 2つのものを所有することになった理由があります
幸福と楽を求めたのです
人間は幸福と楽を求めたんですね
食い物に加えて 食っただけではダメだ
幸福になりたい 楽になりたいと思ったんです
無知な人類に先を読めないんです
推測すらできないんです
将来の 新しいものを開発するが
目の前の利益しか見えません
一つの問題 悪くですね
を解決すると 想定外の新たな問題がたくさん現れます
例えば子供が落ち着かないし
もうイライラしているし
それで我々はゲーム機あげるんです
ああ 現代部品ですね 大層分が下ると
それで子供はそれに夢中になると
子供の脳みそが壊れていくんですね
それで依存したらどうにもならなくなっちゃうんですね
取り上げられなくなるんです
学校で厳しく学校に持ってくるなよと言ったっても
学校では授業に頭がいかないんです
ゲームの次の技を考えているんです
だから皆様にはできないけど
子供と対等で仲良しで喋ることできる
私はできますからね みんな私はこんな年になっても結局仲良し
あれやこれやとかね 喋るんですね
だからそれでわかるんですね
子供たちがこの間違った道を進んでいくこと
だけど私はお説教はしません
だから 例えば想定外 今のある自然破壊
環境破壊 空気汚染 海が汚染
それはすべて想定外でしょう
植物の生命力がなくなっちゃって
食べても大した体に影響はない
すべて想定外 農業開発したハチャメチャで
そこで農業開発したテクノロジー
技術を使って育てた野菜やら米やら
あまり良くないとわかってないんです
体には それからジェネティックエンジニアリングまでやっています
遺伝子改良 だから皆様が買う食品を見ると
遺伝子改良していないとフレーズあるでしょ？買わないでください
必ずやっているんです
あと ちょっと失言ですけど
冗談で言ったんだけど
この遺伝子改良していない大豆でこの納豆を作りましたと
私は何も自慢していない
なってないのかと調べるんで
なんか怪しいような気がします
だってコマーシャル文明知ってますからね
コマーシャル文明は嘘の世界でしょ
・・・そこでこの方程式はわからない
人間 方程式っていうのは
一つの人類の問題 解決すると
想定外の考えることはできない
推測もできない 新たな問題がたくさん現れる
それで苦労して苦労して
その中で一つ解決する
そうするとまた新たな問題がたくさん現れてくる
この結果で これで IT 開発もそういう同じ世界です
IT 開発も初期時代から私はもう知って
ずっと知って年取ったんだからね
よくわかるんです それで AI っていうのは
アーティフィシャルインテリジェンスというのは
そんなにまだまだできてないんです
ちょこちょことあるんだけど
大したことはないんです
それも何か問題解決 解決しようとやる
例えばロボットあるでしょ
そこで今 日本でも研究していますけど
この介護ロボット だから考えているのは
人間が全く手を加えなくても
ロボット自体がすべて判断して介護してあげると
それは相当お金もかかる
時間もかかりますけど
最近は早い スピードも速いし
競争もあるし もう怒り
嫉妬 憎しみもあるんだから
お互いにね だからなんとか早く作るかもしれませんだけどね
安心できますかね 寝たきりのすべてロボットに任せて
ドア閉じると で ロボットは適当な時に起こして
お風呂に入れてあげて
拭いてあげて ご飯作って食べさせて
その人喋るんだったら
ロボットもそれに反応して喋ったり
音楽聴きたいなと言ったら
何か好きな曲は何？と聞いてね
あれやと言ったら さっさとそれは自分でロボットがダウンロードして
それ鳴る えらい夢の話ですね
この連中知らないのは
そういう介護問題解決すると新たな問題が現れてくるんです
じゃあ あのロボットはなんぼかかると思う？できたならば億単位でしょ
1,000万あれば人間介護を頼むことができるでしょ
結局は だから何なのかと
はい ヒストリーオブポゼッション
所有の歴史 さーっといきます
不可欠の衣食住 衣食住
薬 所有することは自然です
それは自然です しかし
感情で必要ない量を超えると問題が起きます
不可欠なものにも 食べるもの
着るものなどなどにも感情が割り込んじゃうと
我々は量を超えちゃうんです
秩序を壊すんです そこでトラブルが起こるんです
余裕があるので 欲しいものに手を出す
それから人々に余裕があるんだから
フリータイムあるんだから
欲しいものに手を出すんです
欲に制限がないので 欲しいものを手に入っても
満足と喜びは簡単に消えます
せっかく楽しく生活していたのに
欲しいものを取りたいなと思ったところで
人々が狙っていた楽しみ
幸福が消えちゃったんです
自然と生きられる環境まで破壊して
欲しいものを作る 売る
買う でしょ あれは自然破壊する
生きられる環境まで破壊して
欲しいものを作っている
売っている 買っている
手に入らないものの場合は精神的に悩む
だからもうもともと悩んでるんだけど
何でも手に入らないんだから
その分いくらでも悩みます
技術の開発とともに欲しいものの値段が上がる一方です
だから欲しいものを作るでしょ
どんどん技術開発するんです
そうすると 値段が上がる
アップル携帯は 20 万でしたっけ？そんな価値があるのかと
例えば時計もありますね
100万 500万とかね
何なのかよくわからないんですね
1,000円の時計もありますけどね
それもちゃんと時間は教えてくれますよ
よくわからない だから値段が上がりますよ
欲しいですが 所有できないものの方がはるかに多い
例えばデパートでも行ってみたらどう？我々は男たちは時計売り場なんかに行って一回りしてきますよ
全財産売っても買えないぐらい高い時計もあります
だから所有できるものよりは所有できないものがすごく多いんですね
例えば 現代宇宙旅行も考える人がいるでしょ
まだ実現できないね 例えば宇宙旅行は？宇宙旅行会社作ったら
一つ 2 日間宇宙空間でぐるぐる回って戻るまでどれぐらい料金を払わなくちゃあかんですかね
ハワイに行って帰る程度じゃないでしょ
みんなお正月ハワイに行ってね
2日  3日いて帰ってきますけど
まあそれも金持ちだけですけど
やってるの 宇宙旅行だったらどう？この正月はじゃあ宇宙旅行でもしましょうと
皆様の全財産売って 隣の人の財産も偽装して売らないと
銀行強盗でもしないとできないね
そこでサブスクリプションサービスとシェアリングエコノミーの概念が現れてくるんです
あまりにも高いんだから手に入らない
だから介護ロボットが現れたら
それはレンタルするしかないんです
だから 5億円では買えないんだけど
月々100万払って使うんです
それでも人間雇った方が安いんだけどね
それで介護ロボットあっても
月々100万払える人にしかあのサービスは受けられませんね
まあシェアリングというのは
このシェアですね だから現代人がもう新しいエコノミック哲学が現れたと
将来とこれからサブスクリプション
エコノミー シェアリングエコノミーやで
くだらんこと言うなと
私は言うんです なんだこりゃと
原始人と同じでしょうけど
同じことでしょう 結局は品物の値段が高くなったんです
売れなくなったんです
だからシェアリングで売ろうと
サブスクリプションサービスで
売ろうと だから自分もお寺の事務所の場合でもね
一人計算でプリンター機とかね
まあレンタルするんですね
そこで何年でしょうかと
だから月々どれくらいそれは計算して買った方が楽だよねというのです
どちらかわからない 買ったらメンテナンスはまた払わなくちゃいけないですね
頼んで まあレンタルの場合はまあメンテナンス込み場合も込みない場合もいろいろありますね
どちらかよくわからない
一発でドカンと買うとすごいお金がいくんだから
まあレンタルで まあ使うんですけど
まあどちらでもあんまり差が見えませんね
だから私の世界で考えれば
借りる場合は 例えば絶版になっていて
誰の手にももう入らない
本当か 国会の図書館に行って
ちょっと借りて読んでメモって
できることならちょっとコピーでも取って
あれは所有することは絶対不可能でしょうし
所有する必要もないし
まあ値段的に考えればかなり値段でしょうしね
それだったら意味がわかりますけど
他はよくわからない それから余裕に徐々に高くなる使用料金を払うために苦労する
ここでまた同じ猿で 今どんどん将来社会ではすべてレンタルでしょうに
どんどんレンタル料金が上がるでしょうに
すべてシェアリングでしょうに
シェアリングするためにも人間関係が必要でしょうし
これでちょっと仲が仲違いしたら別なグループ考えなくちゃいけないし
それなかなか見つからないしね
例えば同じ会社に行く場合は
4人で車シェアリングする
お互いなんかちょっと人間だからね
喧嘩もするでしょうに
お前ともう口きかないとか
同じ車で乗れなくなっちゃうんですね
しかし  4人グループでなければ
車シェアリングできなくなる
じゃあ別な人へ探せと
探せなくなるのね こんなもう大きい問題生まれますよ
もういくらなんでも人間考えてないんだけど
車シェアリングは今日本でやってますからね
車シェアリングで自然守れますよと
一人一人車1台に乗るよりはね
とかね 大したことはないんだけどね
そんなもんで ものを所有するほどの満足が得られる
得られるか否かは問題です
だからものを所有しなくてもいい時代になってるんです
問題は ものを所有して
すごく昔 我々は喜んだでしょ
買ったぞとかね 自慢したでしょ
友達に ほら これ持ってますよと
あの喜びは今ないね 簡単で
自分が結構いい車買っちゃったら
これ一応苦労して買っちゃったよとかね
ああ いいねと友達にも言う
もっと安い値段で同じ高級車レンタルする
あるいはシェアリングすると自慢できないね
これはレンタル これはシェアリングして
この人と 結局は人が必死で求めていた楽しみが消えていくんです
そうすると 楽しみに幸福に飢えている人間が将来どうするかと
天才にも理解できないんです
ノーベル賞を取っている哲学者にも読めないんです
それが人間の問題 だからイグノランスイズゴッド
次 時間的に休憩するべきかどうか分からない
ちょっと時間になったらいいけど
今 3時ですので ちょうど1時間半ぐらい
うん 一つ二つで休憩にします
まだたくさんあるんだけどね
ディシーススステーニングトリートメント
これ日本訳したんだけど
病を保持する治療合ってるかどうか私わかりませんね
トリートメントはトリートメントです
治療は治療です しかし
治療の狙いは病を大事に放っておく
周りの問題に手当をする
いわゆる関連性というんでしたっけ？病とは所有欲です
ひどい病気です 治療は欲しいものを与えることです
あ 欲しいと悩んでいると
泣いていると 欲しいものが
はい どうぞ 金くれとあげている
病はそのままでしょ 所有欲が変わるたびに新しいものを与える
例えばお腹が空いた ご飯が欲しいと言った人にご飯を
はい どうぞ あ よかった
ご飯もらって その人は喜びます
そこでまた所有欲まであるんですね
ご飯そのままで食べられないんだよと
じゃあふりかけ あ このままでは喉が渇くんだ
はい お茶 所有欲は消えてないんですね
その例はしょうがないんだけど
現代では新たな所有欲を無理に作ってでも開発した品物を売るんです
これはコマーシャル世界ですね
我々なかった所有欲が作ってくれるんです
だからもう本当に笑い話でしょうに
今まで困ることはなかったのに
ちょっとテレビ見たら
ちょっとネットに繋げたら
下半身からドカンと入っちゃって
所有欲を掻き立てるんです
あのテレビショッピングチャンネルありますね
あれ ちょっと見て いかにあの下手な連中が人間の所有欲を掻き立てるのかと
だからもう私は見たことあるんですから
すっごく苛立つんです
苛立つんですね あ うるさい
もういいや もうここでストップしなさいよと
大体６回 ８回ぐらい同じ言葉を繰り返し繰り返すんです
あれ 洗脳しようと思ってるんですね
だから 私のような人間だったら
これは洗脳ではなくて
えらいストレスになっちゃうんですね
治らない所有欲に病んでいるので
品物やサービスを与える組織に依存して奴隷になります
これからの世界時代ですね
それは 例えばあのジョブスさんが言ったのは
やっぱり携帯をあの iPhone を作って
ここまでやる必要あるのかと
そこまで人は必要と思ってなかった
彼の言葉は人間は知らんやと
自分に何が欲しいかと
作っちゃえば乗るんだよと
乗ったでしょ それで俺は儲かると
儲かっても死んじゃう
なんだけどね そこで我々の欲に
欲しいもの 所有欲にものを与えて与えている
だから我々は今  IT に依存していますね
IT は自分で管理できない
データ取る 送る それで終わり
自分のデータはクラウドに保存して自慢する
クラウドにあるんだから大丈夫やと
でも誰がクラウド管理してますかね
絶対知らないね 会社がいるんです
その人の言いなりになっちゃうんです
自分のクラウドのデータがあって
他の人に絶対取れないと言える
そこで政府も金融関係も何でもかんでも IT に依存すると
IT 会社にみんな束縛されちゃうんです
みんな脅された状態になるんです
奴隷になります とにかく
もしかすると鉄の檻にいた猿には
まあ一応ステンレススチールの檻を作ってくれる
鉄が錆びたら猿にそれを破って逃げることもできたんだけどね
ステンレススチールになっちゃうとどうにもならん
将来に一部の人間には
もしかするともっとプラチナの檻でも作ってくるのかも
檻は何であろうとも檻の中に閉じ込められてるんだからね
自由がないでしょう はい
それでブラッドフューチャー
ブラッドにも知ってますね
もうモヤモヤモヤモヤで何も見えない
すりガラスから見たような状態
ブラッドっていうのはブラッドフューチャー
だから将来っていうのはもう見えないね
先は読めないっていうことですね
ワンパターンの流れなら先を読めます
物事はワンパターンで流れるならば
先を読めます 優れた AI に瞬時にいかなる問題も解決できるかもしれません
AI ロボットなんかできちゃうと
人間には 1 週間もかかる問題はサッと答え出してくれるかも
しかし メガ組織に依存してロボットのように生きる将来の人間にどんな問題起こるのか
起こるのかわかりませんよ
そこでこの AI にしたっても
このアルゴリズムだから
これ単純な流れなんです
ただ ロボットみたいに複雑な機械の場合は
シンプルなアルゴリズムじゃなくて
いろんなものを乗せて乗せて乗せてシステムを作っているんです
例えばロボットに 将来のロボットに私は昼ご飯食べたいんだから
私に必要なものを案内してくださいと言ったら
ロボットが私の生まれてから全部データ読んで
私の遺伝子データも読んで
私の健康状況を全部読んで
今日昼までどれぐらいエネルギー消費したからとサーッとそれも読んで
じゃあこれぐらいのエネルギーはこの子の材料から取ってくださいとわかって
その料理をあなたはあの店のこの料理を買ってくださいと
大体 1 分以内で教えてくれる
だから私は馬鹿みたいに行って
その店に行って そのロボットが出した料理を買ってもらう
ありがたいね だから私の健康管理は自分が困らなくていいやと
ロボットが答え出してくれるんだと
で 私たちは何食べようか
その気分で その瞬間で決めるでしょ
あれは非科学的だからね
ロボットは科学的にアルゴリズムに則って遺伝子まで読んで答えを出してますから
しっかりした答えです
しかし それで生の人間はどうなるのかと
自分は考える必要なくなる
誰もする必要なくなる
しかし 幸福になりたいと
あの衝動そのままでしょ
所有欲の病はそのままでしょ
だから将来人間どんな反応をするのかとわからない
いくらか推測はありますけど
知識人の間ではね 私もまあその可能性もあるんだけどね
答えもあるんだよという風で言いたいんだけどね
人間の存在欲 所有欲 感情をなくして心の安穏を与える AI は作れないからです
人間を解脱に達することをやってくれる AI はないんです
AI は所有欲を掻き立てるための機械でしょ
無知と欲がすべての開発の親なので
仕方がありません はい
それで一旦休憩いたします
仏教のセクションになります
はい では始まります はい
これから仏教はどう見ているのかと
無常という正当学者の世界
一番最初にぶつかるのはこのリアリズム versus アイディアリズムなんですね
現実と観念の世界 残念ながら
現代人よりは仏教は厳しく現実好きなんです
現代時代は科学や現実やリアリティや
言ったっても感情 感情
感情ばっかりで 仏教の場合は現実を見極める
支えがなければ命は成り立たない
それ一つの現実です だから俗世間はいろいろ
最初は神が支えているんだと
それで科学者はもう神がまだまだ逃げ隠れしてまだ消えてないんですね
人の命を支えるものに執着するから所有欲が起きます
なんで所有欲？これ支えるものに執着するんですね
だから微妙なんです 支えがなければ生きられない
支えてくれるものに執着してしまう
自然の流れなんです 幸福を求めるのは
結局生きることが苦だからです
なんですべての生命は幸福を目指しているんですかね
幸福だったら探す必要ないでしょ
これでみんな否定する現実
あなたは不幸だと あなたの生きることは苦である
苦であると現実認めなさいと
ですから 生きる仕組みの中に幸福は存在しない
生きることが苦であるならば
生きることの中に幸福を探しても探しても見つからないんです
苦でできているんだからね
だから正反対の特色はそちらに
例えば氷で何か作品を作る
例えば 氷で あの あの氷の酒いっぱいありますね
あのちょっと家の談話室というかね
リビングを作って あのイギリス風のあれ
ファイヤープレイス なんて言いますか
暖炉も作っておく それで氷で火が燃えているような感じでも作る
ちょっとそれ色もペイントしておく
全て氷でできてるでしょ？だからいくらかっこよく暖炉を作って
炎がすごい芸術的にゆらゆらするように作っても
それでゆらゆらの感じを作るために
LED で照明も当ててできますよ
別に 氷の下から光がぐいぐいぐにゃぐにゃぐにゃ上がってきて
また下から上がって見ると
ああ 燃えているんだと錯覚するできるでしょ？だからといって人得られないのは何でしたっけ？暖かさ
氷だから 人間が現実離れだから
これを理解しない この生きることのことが苦でできているんです
だからその中から幸福を探すなよと
幸福は存在しない それを理解してほしいんです
生きていきたいという存在欲がある
次の現実 誰にも生きていきたいという存在欲があるんです
これはわからないならば死にたくないでしょ
誰だって なんか空からその感情が生まれませんよ
生きていきたいということは現実的な気持ちなんです
それは作り出したのは何でしたっけ？それは命は確実に儚いものだからなんです
それがリアリティーなんです
生きていきたいという希望は観念です
これは融合できません
氷の暖炉で暖かさを求めるようなことになるんです
それから日本語だけに行きます
あのザルで水を汲む だから人間やっていることはすべて IT
AI までザルで水を汲むことです
存在欲を支えて楽に生きるために
いかなる工夫をしても
命は儚いことと生きることは苦であることは変わらないんです
だって現実離れでしょ
こんなあれやこれや作ったからといって
新幹線ができたからといって
リニアモーターカーもそろそろ大阪
東京 名古屋 東京間で走るようになったから言ってどうにもなりませんよ
それでも生きることは苦です
それでも生きていきたい気持ちはそのままです
欲しいものを手に入れても
感情と妄想は暴走しているので
限りなく新たな欲しいものが現れます
だから この欲しいもの
必要なものの裏に自分の感情があると
で理解していない これが暴走するんだと理解しない
現代人が感情があって当たり前
喜怒哀楽あって当たり前
感情を描きたくて何が悪い？コマーシャルにアメリカの俳優さんと女優さん雇って大金払って何が悪い？みんな楽しく見ているんだから
それで 100万円の品物をみんなね 500
万で買ってくれるんだから何が悪いってでしょ
だからみんな現実離れで感情って聞いてんやと
これは暴走するんだと
そこでどこかでどこかちょっとテロ行為を受けただけで
ものすごく大騒ぎするんです
大したことないんです
そんなのは ちょっと感情が暴走しただけで
テロ行為しないで この大会社たちやっていることがもっとテロ行為でしょうに
マンモス薬会社やっていることもっとテロ行為でしょうに
みんなやっていて 10
人ぐらい殺したことを大げさにするんです
感情を抑えようとすると落ち込んで苦しくなる
時々人々はこれわかった
感情を抑えを抑えると
これうまくいかない 落ち込むんです
感情に蹴られるままに走ることをやめて
フリータイムを使って生きることは何と観察するべきです
これは仏教の提案です
あのね フリータイム使ってくださいと
昔の原始人より皆様には余るほどフリータイムがあるんです
朝ごはん探して食べるためには
すぐコンビニに行ったらすぐ買って食べられます
全然時間かかりません
他全てフリータイムなんです
昔と違う 昔は朝ごはん食べられないんですよ
朝起きて狩りに行くんです
行って走り回って回って
やっと獲物が取れたらありがたくて
取れなかったら手ぶらで戻る
だからフリータイムなかったね
今の人々にはフリータイムあり余っているんです
それで何する？芸術鑑賞
テレビを見る ネット依存
携帯依存 ゲーム依存 そういうこと
かわいそう あのフリータイムで生きるって何だと感謝してよと
こんなもうレミングみたいにみんなと一緒に走るなよと
生きることに不可欠なものが揃ったら
余る時間がフリータイム
フリータイムというのはそういうことなんです
得ることは苦 得たものを保持することも苦
それでたくさん苦があるんですよ
生きること自体も苦だけど
その中で所有得ることも苦で
得たものを保持することも苦なんです
苦があるからものを欲しくなりますね
当然 それから必要にもなります
例えばご飯必要でしょ？苦があるからなんです
たとえ衣食住薬であっても
得苦と保持苦があります
得苦と保持苦 いわゆる得る
皆様も結構朝から晩まで会社で仕事をしているでしょうに
これ 衣食住 衣食住薬のためですよ
だからもう得苦もあって
給料もらった給料も大事に使わなくちゃいけないから
保持苦もあります 得るものが消えると苦が増えます
それで消えるとまた苦しみが生まれてきます
所有欲で所有すると 所有欲が消えて幸福にはなりません
それ一つの現実なんです
所有欲がある 所有する必要ではなくて
それで欲しい欲しい欲しいといろんなものを取っちゃいますね
取っても取っても欲しいという気持ちはそのまま
あー消えました まあすっかりしたということにならないんです
だから自己観察してみてください
欲しいものが手に入ったから
欲しいという感情消えたのかと
消えてないんです だから
欲しいもの手に入っても人は幸福になりません
外国 旅行したいな 欲しいなと若者思って
それでバイトして金貯めて外国旅行する
でもそれで幸福になりませんよ
ただ 所有欲の苦も増えて得る苦も得たものを守る苦も加算されます
欲しいものを手に入ったら
この手に入れる苦があるでしょうに
すごい大事な欲しいものだから
すごい真剣に守らなくちゃあかんですね
それでまた新たな苦が生まれてくるんです
幸福になろうとする人の生き方のなんか変ですね
結果は不幸と苦しみになります
だから頑張ってちょうだい
幸福になってよと 結果は不幸になります
これは現実を見る人は知っています
どうせ頑張って会社で頑張っても
いろいろプログラム 新しいものを作って
どこかの大会社に売っちゃって
それで金儲けてやって苦しくなるだけです
それで手放すことと安楽って何なのかと
まあ面倒くさいんだから簡単な例を書きました
ペットとして馬あるいは虎などを飼うことができるって楽しいでしょう
私も象が好きですからね
一頭飼いたいんです 楽しいと思うやつ
象と遊んだり話したり
いろいろね 背中に乗ったり
象さんもものすごく飼い慣れるんです
で それで幸福になるのかと
しかし ついてくる苦しみは楽しみより多いんです
じゃあまあ 私を犯人にして考えてください
私は象さんを買ったと
それ楽しめる私には大変な象さんが巨体だからね
それなりの土地が必要でしょうし
大量に食べるんだから
毎日食べ物をあげなくちゃいかんしね
すごい敏感な動物だから
いつでも行って可愛がってあげて
慰めてあげたりしなくちゃ
私何もできなくなるんですね
それにかかるお金 それで
たとえ私が象を買ったとしましょう
私は幸せになりたければ
やるべきことは何でしたっけ？象さんを誰かに動物園にでも持っていってくださいと
移動お金はこちらで払いますと
それなんです それで楽になるんです
手放したら長持ちする安楽感を感じる
しかし 諦めずに寂しいと思ったら苦しくなる
例えば 私は象さんを動物園に寄付しました
あー可愛かったねと思っちゃうと
また苦しみが出てきますよ
だから諦めることも必要ですね
ですから 欲しいという感情まで捨てなくてはならない
だから捨てることで楽しいんだけど
感情まで捨てなくちゃいけないんです
時々私は人にいろいろ必要という人にいろいろ物をあげるんだけど
何年経ってからその人
あの この間なんとかなんとかね
あなたからもらったこと
これはまだ使っていい
忘れてるんです 私があげたの？とか
覚えてないんで なんで覚えてないのかというと
あげたら感情までもう削除
私のものであったというデータまで削除するんで
脳から だからもらった人はもう 1週間だったら大丈夫ですけどね 1
年ぐらい経ってから聞いちゃうと
もう私はわからない もうそんなことあげた覚えがないんです
闇雲に捨てるだけでは
苦に対する答えではありません
だから言って 闇雲に捨てろ捨てろとかね
それが答えじゃないんです
そちらに仏教では精密な科学的な答えがあるんです
あなたの家を誰かにあげてください
ホームレスになる そんなことではないんです
捨てるのは何でしたっけ？愛着
家があってもいいんです
家に対する愛着を捨てるんです
物を所有しないだけで幸福になりませんよ
衣食住薬を捨てるとは単純な自殺でしょ？だから闇雲に捨てるというわけじゃないんです
目的は自殺ではなく幸福でしょうに
執着がなくても 愛着がなくても
衣食住薬を所有することはできます
なんで 例えば別な例えで言いましょうか
食べるものの上にちょっとスプレーペインティングする
おにぎりって 黒い白い
もっといい格好にしたいなとか
ご飯の方に青い色のペイントをおにぎりの海苔の方に何かちょっとペンキで何か模様でも描いて
それから食べる 意味がないでしょう
美しくなくても食べられるでしょう
もしおにぎりにスプレーペイントをかけたら毒でしょう
だから所有欲でご飯を食べるとご飯は毒になる
所有欲で服を着たら服が毒になる
精神に体ではないんです
まあ体にも毒になる場合ありますけどね
あまりもおしゃれしすぎちゃって
家に愛着あると毒になる
精神的に悩む羽目になる
愛着なくても丁寧に家の管理して生きることはできますよ
例えば自分の部屋を掃除する
愛着はいらないよ 公園も掃除してください
頼む だって公園を掃除するとか
愛着ないでしょうに 掃除ぐらいはできるでしょうに
愛着がなくても だから
この人類の歴史の中で
そちらで人間が間違った一歩なんです
ホモサピエンスが出てきて
洞窟石器時代生活するときはもう必要なものはあって
必要なもので終わればいいのに
愛着を作ってみたんですね
それからずっと人類がそれをやってくるんです
進化に合わせていうと
でも 生命はもともと限りない愛着を持っているんです
執着欲はね 生まれる時も同じ
だから生まれるんですよ
ですから人は必要不可欠なものについて量をする
だから愛着さえなければ
必要不可欠なこの量を知ることはできます
だから仏教で言っているこの鉄道をしなさいとかね
量を量ってご飯を食べろ
そんなことを言ったのは
これは 一般の馬鹿者たちに実行できる世界じゃないんです
すごく理性のある 観察能力ある人の行動の生き方なんです
欲しいものを最低限にする
そういう人はもう愛着ないんだから
現代社会で生きてるんだから
例えば もうその生き方をする人は携帯は買う
使う だって まあでもそういうのは制限リミットするんです
なぜならば 欲しいものを追っかけていると切りがない
欲しいものは危険で 欲しいとは愛着の話なんですね
必要と違います 両方とも執着なく
愛着なく使用する 例えば
まあわかりやすく言いましょう
人が悟ったとしましょう
その人は結構おしゃれするんですね
悟ったからおしゃれやめます
やめる必要ないんです
別に 普段通りに しかし
今度は落ち着いて丁寧におしゃれをする
良しってやる それだけ
はい ちょっと訓練は教えます
幸福の訓練１ 借りる 楽しいね
借りることだからね 借りてください
何も所有することは不可能です
本当に現実主義で見ると
あれは勘違いです これは私のもの
これは私は所有しているっていうのは
あれって勘違いです 現実的に見ると
これは不可能なことなんです
不可能だとわかったら
所有欲が消えちゃうでしょ
そうすると借りてるんですね
すべて借りて使っているのだと発見するんです
すべて借りているんです
我々は だから借りたものを使うときは使い方があるんです
暴走はできません 決まりあります
借りたもの だから一般人よりは仏教の人々が
例えば億万長者の仏教徒がいる
億万長者の一般人がいる
億万長者の仏教徒違いますよ
もっと正しく生きているんです
使用人を怒鳴ったり 侮辱したりはしない
借りたものだから 採算を悪用しない
裏金を使っていろいろ悪いことをしようとはしない
丁寧に法律を守って生きる
欲の感情の一般人が億万長者だったら
拡大しなくちゃあかんやとかね
あれやこれやとかもハチャメチャ苦労する
税金払わないためにどんな工夫すればいいんでしょうかとかね
マイホームは私の所有物ではありません
だいたいみんなマイホームには執着してるでしょ
日本の方々は 夢ですからね
でも たとえマイホームを作っても
あれはマイホームじゃないんです
借りたんです ですから
当然使用条件があるんで
みんな知ってるでしょ？自分が土地を買って家を作っても
固定なんとか税金払わなくちゃあかんでしょ
この地方税金払わなくちゃあかんでしょ
俺の家だからね 返れと言える？ではない
役所から来て これぐらいの家で
これぐらい土地で だからあんた 1年これぐらい払いなさいと
だからレンタルしていますよ
権利書は自分で持っていても
結局は 仕事も車も携帯も借りたものです
わがままで自分勝手に使用することはできません
今は皆様 やっぱり会社の携帯を買ったってもね
意味がないね すべて会社がいじっているんです
自分にはほんの小さな窓口しか開けてないんです
食べ物は買い出し 食べるものと着るものだけは返す必要ないんです
ない借り物です しかし
使用料金がかかりますね
ただでご飯降ってこないね
だからそれは借りるものになるんです
ただ返さなくても結構です
それだけ 幸福の訓練２
私のものではない これはちょっともう
ちょっと深い瞑想なんです
何一つも私のものではないことを発見します
それにはブッダが説かれたすごいいいプログラムがあります
目に...ちょっと紹介します
目に見えるもの 仏教用語で色というんです
は 私のものではない 当然でしょ
皆様にこのスクリーン見えますね
皆様のスクリーン？当たり前ね
私のものじゃない 色を感じる目も視覚も私のものではない
じゃあ目は私のものじゃないんです
どんな風に光を受け止めるかと目が決めるんです
それで視覚が生まれるでしょ
これ漢字合ってるかどうかわかりませんだけどね
あれって脳が勝手に作るんです
だから スクリーンに何をどんな光を映ろうか
皆様の脳みそは自分勝手に何か現象を作るんですね
視覚さえ因縁によって
条件によって起こる結果で
自分の勝手で希望で起こるものではないんです
じゃあ皆様希望してください
この字がぐるぐるぐるぐる光り離しながら回ってちょうだいと思って
そうなる？ならないね
だから自分のものじゃないんです
見たものから生まれる楽しみ
嫌な気持ちも私のものではありませんよ
では この花を見てください
皆さんは何かの感覚が生まれるでしょう
楽しみか嫌な気持ちとかね
では この花を見て こちらでコウモリが傘開いているような怖い感じ
作ってみて どうですか？できた？できませんよ
だから これを見たらどんな気持ちが生まれるのかというと
自己感 自分で管理できるものじゃないんです
だから私のものではありませんよ
しかし 色に愛着するのは自分勝手で法則違反です
だから色っていうのは見えるものでしょ？見えるものに愛着はあるでしょう
あれって法則違反です
あなたのものじゃないんです
隣の奥さんに恋を抱いていいわけじゃないでしょ
法則違反でしょ だから
目に入るすべてのものは私のものじゃないんです
だから愛着を作る必要はありません
所有欲は成り立たないんです
現実を見ましょう 至って簡単にそれはわかります
それですっごく心が自由になるんです
今 目だけ説明したんです
だからこれ 法則違反だから
そこをストップする 法則を破ったらなおさら苦しくなるんです
生きることも苦しいなのに
例えば厳しく刑務所に入れて苦しんでるんですよ
それで刑務所の中で暴れ回って攻撃して
人をぶん殴ったり 他の囚人ぶん殴ったり
警備の方々ね ぶん殴ったりすると
なおさら大変でしょ 暴言吐いたりすると
だから刑務所に入れたならば
おとなしく起きる時間で起きて
食べる時間で食べて 消灯時間で寝ていれば楽でしょ
楽と言ったっても 刑務所に入れたことは苦しいんだけど
その程度で終わるでしょ
だから我々は法則を破ってますよ
見るものは私のものにしたがる
私のものだと勘違いするということ
これは目のプログラムですね
このプログラムを眼耳鼻舌身意と色声香味触法に実行してみるんです
目だけじゃなく 耳も同じ
鼻も同じ 舌も同じ だからあのフレーズ唱えながらこの実行して中で
そうすると何となく精神的に自分が自分の心のプログラムが変わっていくんです
これすごい強力な瞑想なんです
私はただの概念で 私っていうのは私
あれただの概念です 眼耳鼻舌身に分けてみると
何も私のものはないでしょ
だから私のと思ったのは
意識のちょっとした概念だけなんです
実体がないのだと発見します
現象は無常で流れるだけで
存在欲に脅されて苦労する必要はないと理解することで
揺らがない安穏が現れます
それが幸福に達する道なんです
これでこのプログラムで解脱に達しますよ
悟れます いたってシンプルですね
システムが勝手に壊れるまで安穏でいられます
だから悟った人はこのシステムがね
因果法則で壊れていくでしょ
見守ってるんです 見守ってるの
勝手に壊れていくまで
それだけ あれ欲しい これ欲しい
あいつは嫌とかないんです
だって私がいないんだから
はい 最後にこの愛着と苦悩の関係
この経典とか出したくなったんだけど
私は体ボロボロで痛くてもうしょうがなく
もうもう遠慮していないんです
何かが所有する 必要だからでしょ
所有したものが欲しかったからですね
必要あるいは欲しかった
私は 2つも一緒にしたんで
今は 今まで必要と欲しいは 2つに説明しましたけどね
しかし 所有した自分が必ず変わる
ああ どうしようもない
所有したんだけど 所有した主人が変わっていくんですね
所有物が要らなくなったり
使えなくなったりすることは苦です
だから自分が変わっちゃうと取ったものが苦になるんです
例えばすごい高級車買っちゃった
まあ 1週間ぐらい楽しく
高級車買う人っていうのは金があるんだからね
まあ楽しく運転していたんだけど
脳出血で倒れたと どうしますか
買った車は 運転できないんです
だから苦しくなるんです
車見ると車椅子でちょっと見ると
ああ 乗れなくなったと
あれ すごいショックでしょ
自分が変わったんだから
所有物が無常だからから次所有したものも無常だから変わるんで
このお花はもう枯れますからね
しょうがないんです でお金もかかったことでしょうに
でも枯れて捨てますね
そうすると苦しくなりますよ
まあいくらでもその理由を出せますけどもね
自分のね 可愛い子供がね
18歳になって二十歳になっちゃうと出ていく
いやなんですね 喧嘩までして寝ていく
嫌なこと だから自分が所有していたんだからね
その物体が変わったんです
それは苦しみが生まれるんです
愛着によって得る苦 保持苦
失う苦が変わります そこでちょっと方程式が現れるんです
所有するものに愛着があります
どれぐらい愛着あるかということによって苦が変わるんです
割り箸の場合は 得る苦
保持苦 失う苦が微々たるもので感じませんね
弁当を食べようと思って
割り箸をパシッと置いたら折れてしまっちゃったね
あー死にますとなる？なんで不幸ですか？ないんです
そこら辺 なんとか箸を取ることできますからね
どこでもタダでくれるんだからね
コンビニ行ったら割り箸もう1人ちょうだいと言ったらくれるんです
だから愛着が少ない しかし
割り箸が必要です 所有しているんです
しかし 苦がないんですね
なんで？愛着ないからです
運転中 車体に傷ができたらどう？少々苦を感じますね
なんで？車に愛着があるからです
家に洪水で水が入ったらどうですか？もっとすごい苦しみを感じます
家族の年寄りが亡くなっていくの苦と
我が子が亡くなる時の苦は同じ？同じじゃないね
80歳あるいは 90歳のおばあさんが亡くなった
ちょっと悲しい それだけ
ちょっと寂しい  12歳の子供が病気で死ぬ
あるいは事故で死ぬ 同じ悲しみ？違うでしょ
耐えがたい悲しみが生まれるんですね
なんで？愛着 ポイントは愛着
愛着が苦しみの上下を決めるんです
調度を決めるんです 愛着が強いほど
保持苦 失う苦がひどくなります
ひどくなるんです だから
単純な妄想的な愛着で
例えば子供が10歳で事故で死んだとしましょう
もう子供が死んじゃったんです
もういないんです もうあの世に行っているんです
あの世の生命というのは
自分の子供じゃないんです
もう しかし あの両親の心には
愛着が残ってます それはもう感情で妄想だからね
愛着が その人々は延々と苦しませるんです
だから愛着こそが犯人です
所有することでもないんです
所有する意図がある限り
苦はついてきます だからまあ所有したい
所有したいという気持ちがある限り
苦しみは逃げません 自分からはね
だから所有することは不可能であると借りるだけだと理解したら
そこで苦しみが寄ってこないんです
本当にシンプルなんです
これ 私の体と思っちゃうと
ダーンと苦しみがついてきます
これ借りたよったら何のこともないんです
それで安穏安全ガイド
所有するものではなく
借りて使う これを覚えてほしいポイントなんで
ガイドだからね 借りたものを丁寧に法則を守って使うが
愛着だけは抱きません
もう自分の周りに揃っているものはすごい丁寧に使います
テーブルを使ったならば
綺麗に拭いて置いておきます
座布団じゃなくて布団を使ったならば
綺麗に畳んで置いておきます
しかし 愛着はないんです
借りたものです たとえ自分の家の中のものであっても
自分の名前まで書いているカップがマグカップがあるかも
でも借りたものです カップはカップの形で壊れることもできますからね
だから 綺麗に使って 綺麗に洗って
美しくカップ様を保管しておく
自分は関係ないです そういう決まりはすごいいいですよ
体も感覚も思考も感情も借りたものよりもっとひどいこと
体も借りたもの 感覚あるでしょ
勝手に生まれますね 今私は立ってるんだけど
結構体が壊れちゃって痛いんですよ
痛くはなりたくないんだけど
痛いんです 勝手です だからなんでこの感覚は勝手に生まれるんだから
自分のものじゃないんです
思考はどうですかね 思考は思考の勝手で
感情は？感情は感情の勝手で
病んでいる人にとっては
どうすることもできない状態になるんです
だから自我は借りたものだとわかった人だけ救われます
すべて因縁によって一時的になる
成り立つですね  成り立つ
なります だからすべて一時的です
因縁によって成り立つんです
手挙げです だから放っておくしかないんです
放っておく必要ない だって自分がいないんだから
所有は不可能です 愛着はおらかな態度です
自分とは組み立てた現象だとわかる人に
所有も所有欲も それについてくる悩み苦しみもありませんと
だいたいこれで終わりような終わったような気がします
で だから基本的に仏教のアプローチというのは
人間には 所有欲があるんですね
俗世間はそういう所有欲を大事にして
ものだけ提供する だから所有欲は勝手に拡大する
勝手に拡大しないともの売れないでしょ
そうするとコマーシャルで所有欲をかき立ててくれる
それは俗世間の世界 仏教は所有欲をなくしてあげる
終わり 誰にも掴むことはできなくなるんです
コマーシャルしてもしてもびくともしない
その人は はい それで終わりです
ありがとうございます
拍手はい ではもう一度は
今日の法話会で皆様にこの智慧の光をね
お布施した あの まあ黒田孝平さんにも
ご家族の方々にも深く感謝いたします
幸福でありますように
ブッダの御加護がありますようにと誓願いたします
サーブーサーブーサー
それからこの供養したいと思っている
この黒田玲子様ですね
おばあ様のね おばあ様にも
あのの 幸福でありますように
解脱に達することができますようにと回向いたします
サーブーサーブーサー
長い時間 あの話はなんかわけもわからない苦しい話になったんだけど
今日は何の冗談もなかったしね
だから大変長い時間 皆様もよく修行しました
皆様にも三宝の御加護がありますように
幸福でありますように
心が清らかになりますように
安穏に達することができますようにと誓願いたします
サーブーサーブーサー
はい よろしいですか では
最後の誓願をご一緒に唱えましょう
ドゥッカムパンターチェニドゥッカ
バヤムパンターチェニバヤ
ソーカムパンターチェニソーカ
ホントゥサンデッピパーニノー
もう一度 ドゥッカムパンターチェニドゥッカ
バヤムパンターチェニバヤ
ソーカムパンターチェニソーカ
ホントゥサンデッピパーニノー
苦しむものの苦しみがなくなりますように
怯えるものの怯えが消えますように
悲しむものの悲しみがなくなりますように
一切の生命が楽のごとくありますように
ありがとうございます
カンティーパラマンタポーティティンカーニッバーナパラマンワダンティーブッダ